let's talk about sha Strickland ladies
and gentlemen sha Strickland UFC 297
coming up this Saturday it's going to be
amazing I I am not going to miss this
fight Sean Strickland as you know mocked
Bud Light when you know the whole D of
anything happens budlight then sponsors
UFC Shan Strickland comes out and says I
can't I can't wait to reform you I'm
gonna I'm GNA save you budlight it's a
hilarious video and we were all really
excited for the moment when Shawn
Strickland would give a press conf
confence knowing that he's going to sit
there in front of all of the press and
just go off and he did it is spectacular
in fact he goes a little a little heavy
with it so I'd say I don't completely
agree with everything he said so far but
yo this he's got a couple clips that are
going viral we're going to play for you
and uh let's start with the covid
lockdowns one here we go thanks Sean
Neil Davidson from the Canadian press
welcome to Canada oh congratulations
yeah the Canadian press man were
you a were you a uh a covid bank account
stealer too were you on board with that
no are you left wing or right wi were
you a were you a trudo we got one of we
got one of the commies
with stands were you
non-biased I think I'll lost the
questions think oh we know maybe
I should just pass on this
he's going to go back he's going to go
back and give my bank account
information of
Trudeau wow man well it's probably a
good bank account
it probably is a really good bank
account I love that he just came out and
dropped commies yes but like the
journalist didn't even say anything he's
just sitting there like I'm going to
call you a commi I'm going to call you
out but now I want to I to play this
clip for you this one goes hard he there
there some people on the right even who
are like it's a little too heavy for me
cuz he made some comments about trans
people in the past too and they're like
yeah yeah yeah no we agree with calling
out budlight and all these things but my
my view is like take the big ask
budlight sponsors UFC and this is is
what you get when they do I'm going to
play the clip for you uh we've got a
pretty supportive gay and lesbian
community in this city I did want to ask
you about something you wrote A couple
of years ago you said if I had a gay son
I would think i' oh look another another
the I'm saying a swamp you guys a swamp
you've become a champion you've become a
star and and someone let me ask you
something are you are you are you gay no
are are you let me know are you gay can
I can I get answer well I'm asking this
is a part of are you are you a gay man
I'm an ally of the community okay if you
had a son then he was
had a son he was gay you'd be like oh
man you don't you don't want a grandkid
no problem with it oh man well dude
you're a weak man dude like
you're part of the problem you
elected Justin Trudeau like with you
when he sees the bank accounts
like you're just pathetic and
and the fact that the fact that you have
no backbone and and has he shut
down your country and seiz bank
accounts you ask me some stupid
like that go
yourself I'm going PA right there this
is not about you know uh uh whether you
support gay people or not he's outright
saying you elect Trudeau he shuts down
bank accounts and this is the question
that I get spot on I do want to ask also
things you said about the trans
Community you said uh this packs October
when they announced the budlight
sponsorship that you'd go so hard on
budlight in your next fight they'll have
to accept me or denounce me when uh when
they know what and will know what they
stand for are you this guy's like this
Canadian is not that Canadian are you
still going to use your fight time to
kind of speak on that here's the thing
about Bud
Light here's the thing about Bud
Light 10 years ago to be trans was a
what a mental illness and now
all of a sudden people like you have
weasel your way in the
world you are you are an infection whoa
you are the definition of weakness
everything that is wrong with the world
is because of you and the best
thing is is the world's not buying it
the world's not buying your
you're pedaling the
world is not saying you know what you're
right chicks have dicks the
world's not saying that world's saying
no there are two genders I don't want my
kids being taught about you know who
they could school I don't want
my kids being taught about you know
their sexual preference like dude this
guy is a enemy you want to look
at the enemy to our world it's
that right there so I just
like to point out he has basically just
made the statement cuz he was asked
about budlight and he said budl light's
going to have to either accept me or
denounce me and then he called this guy
an
infection going a little hard a little
hard but uh when it comes to the
political issues that he's pointing out
these these people who are lying and
pretending to be allies or whatever they
don't actually care they are literally
just weak these journalists in the
United States and in Canada these
leftists most of them I would refer to
them as default liberal they don't
actually care about these issues in fact
many of them don't like the these things
that are being pushed by by the woke
left but they are so weak they will
March in lock step with it yeah it's
interesting leaving Sports I I still get
messages from some of the people I used
to work with and some of the athletes
too they won't go public and say that
they they agree with me but they'll send
me a message and they'll agree with me
so it's unfortunate but I mean this is
refreshing they're weak there's a lot of
weak people out there that they're all
afraid of being canceled and
unfortunately uh there's no endend in
sight but you know Sean's comments are
refreshing I don't always agree with all
of them but this is refreshing that
someone's so transparent and so open
about it it's the only thing that you'll
see in the UFC though the the UFC is
really the only only sport uh division
that will ever do any of this you won't
see it in professional sports regarding
Major League Baseball or NHL or NFL as
we saw today so ultimately it's kind of
refreshing to see people being so open
about it what happened in the NFL today
today there's the new head coach of the
Patriots and he is I think he's the
first black coach for the Patriots and
he said during the press conference that
he sees that if you don't see color that
you are part of the problem and like you
are racist is what he's trying to incend
he does not like Martin go from 20 years
of do your job to this yeah what an
embarrassment for people that don't know
the New England Patriots when Bill
bellich and and Tom Brady were just
destroying the NFL for two decades they
the whole point was do your job do your
job do your job it was focused purely on
the game and they get this new clown in
here and like he it's been a month that
he's been in I think today was just the
press conference the welcoming press
conference Bel just left yeah Bel just
left and this guy's in and the first
thing out of his mouth is I'm going to
screw the Patriots harder yeah like
they're they're doomed they're doomed is
the UFC a place where the athletes can
speak out because the way Dana White
runs it just purely because yeah they're
okay with this they won't there's no
penalties for saying this they'll you
know everyone's allowed to have their
own opinions and that's why I think it's
refreshing cuz you can't do that
anywhere else uh they will jump on you I
think the NHL learned their lesson the
hard way too when they started doing all
these Dei hiring practices and they've
suddenly distanced themselves from it
but they had like a I forgot what her
role exactly was but she was a Dei hire
and she was pretty I mean hockey is a is
a is a heavily white sport there's not
very uh there's not many minorities in
it and she had she was very critical of
that and she was very like we need to
get more minorities involved in it but
they have no interest in being involved
in it so I forced them to do it and so
we're just seeing it all over the place
that's why I I kind of like the UFC and
how they allow their players their
fighters to go out there and speak so
openly is it like single single team
sport like I know single player sports
like golf can the golfers get away with
saying this kind of thing they all can
all professional athletes can the issue
is UFC knows that if they tried
enforcing morality Clauses on these
Fighters they'd have no Fighters you can
go to a golfer and he's going to be like
I don't want to fight I'm just here to
play golf youo Strickland's got
cauliflower ear yeah he is not afraid of
you he doesn't care what you think he's
going to say what he wants to say not
weak like there's other fighting
companies that would pick him up and
like fightings it's all on on Shawn like
what Shawn says is on Shawn in a team
sport what you say reflects on your team
and I think when you're in a team sport
you're kind of indoctrinated like do
your part for the team don't question
the coach stay in line the team is more
important than you are well I I think
that's a component of it but it's it's
generally that while athletes are strong
people that's like what makes you
athlete people who get punched in the
face for a living are like the strongest
of athletes and if you're a dude like
Strickland who gets punched in the face
for a living and actually wins when he
punches others in the face I think he's
undefeated right am I wrong I have to
fact check that I don't know pull that
up I could be I could be wrong about
that I think he is I'm not sure I'm not
I'm not a big UFC guy but my point is
just this you're you're not going to
find on average tougher people and so if
someone comes them and says hey we don't
want you to say these things right it's
a you got a morality Clause these are
the most likely guys to be like oh you
you you I'm going to say what
I want to say that's exactly what he's
doing yeah like like the things he's
saying about budl I'm surpris like Bud
light's got to respond to this I think I
think here's I thing I I know what's
going to happen the far-left will not
touch this they will not come out they
will not criticize Strickland they will
not criticize budlight because they know
they will lose and that will force Bud
Light to issue a statement of support to
Strickland and the UFC in some way so
long as there is no conflict all the
far-left can do is sit down and shut up
yeah yeah he's 90 so he's undefeated um
I thought it was interesting too this
year MLB uh all the teams except the
Rangers didn't have an LGBT plus night
Rangers didn't do it everyone else did
and ultimately the Rangers won the World
Series I I thank God rewards those okay
no no he's lost five fights two by
Knockout by submission latest number
this say he's 28 and five is that just
his total career yeah five five losses
you N9 and0 is that in the UFC or
something let's see had made his
professional debut in 201 let me click
on it the first thing that popped on
Google said yes he
was I got I I'm reading a sports SK they
say that he's lost five 28 and five 128
lost five that's a great record look man
yeah not bad I don't care what you do
but I just think it's fairly obvious if
you're if you're a fighter you're quite
literally a fighter and people who play
basketball are probably just like man
leave me alone you know what I mean it's
it's very very different a lot of pro
skateboarders are coming around those is
really exciting and I think one of the
things that's really important too and I
encourage all these companies to do more
of it there are uh you know I'll be on
Instagram and I'll see a clip from a pro
skateboarder and they're wearing a
Public Square shirt that's how you solve
this when Public Square goes to a pro
athlete in action sports and says we're
going to pay you x amount of dollars per
month wear our shirts put our stickers
on on your gear they say you got it I'm
getting paid guess what now they're not
scared to speak out cuz they'd be like
look I ride for this energy drink
company and if I say this stuff they're
going to fire me now they're like yeah
energy drink company might fire me but I
get paid more more by Public Square and
Rumble anyway so what do I care yep
people can have issues like if if if you
you never know right you might come out
and say something you know
about I don't know oh I just playing
don't like uh shepherd's pie and then it
turns out that the CEO of a company who
sponsors you owns a shepherd's pie you
know freezer food company and he's like
you're hurting our brand so we're
dropping you never know what's going to
offend one of your sponsors so if you've
got sponsors with a wide range of
political backgrounds you're safe and as
more and more companies on the right
sponsor athletes and just anyone who can
be sponsored the more likely it is
they're going to publicly speak up and
defend their values and there are more
people that are coming out and and
pushing back against woke there it is it
is you know kind of getting to a point
where people are standing up and saying
hey no we're not doing this anymore it's
something that it's going to take it's
not something that's going to go away
easily because it it is there's a lot of
money in it first of all there's a lot
of uh people that are true believers the
whole woke thing that's gone into like
when it comes to LGBT and trans and
stuff like that anybody any parent that
helped their child mutilate their body
they are never going to ever let it go
they're going to be true believers for
the rest of their lives because if they
go ahead and say well maybe I was wrong
then they've you know enabled their
child to mutilate their body so there's
there's going to be people that are
going to push back probably for decades
but overall it looks like most the
general consensus is this is not
something that we want dictating our
society which is you know extremely
hopeful and my fingers are crossed but
yeah I think that a lot of the last five
years of of crazy Dei and and child sex
changes was like those kids are adults
now like khloee Cole is very vocal adult
she I don't know she's 19 is she 19 now
or 19 or 20 and she had her double
mastectomy when she was 15 and now was
like how horrible that I was led to do
this to myself and she's like leading
the charge as an adult now kind of
talking back and we're also seeing the
the payout of the parallel economy in
action we talked about parallel economy
two years ago and like we need a
parallel economy then Public Square
appeared then Rumble went public and
like now we see the value of it as
people feel like they can speak out
because they're being sponsored by
companies like that and uh cast Brew
Coffee that's right uh it's preliminary
but cbw coffee not only has an Alex
Stein two times caffeine it's Prime Time
grind Alex Stein's Prime Time grind two
times caffeine but uh we're going to be
sponsoring his show too I love that so
right we're going to make sure that the
people we like and and do fun things the
thing about Alex is that he does a kind
of political comedy it's fun it's
entertaining it's silly it's it's it's
it's levity and so uh you know I'm
talking to him we did the coffee blend
with him and now you know we're we're I
don't know I should say it's a little
early we'll I don't know the blaze is in
is is involved cuz the shows on the
blaze but I'm like yeah let's let's roll
let's do this I want there to be more of
people like Alex Stein because you know
a lot of people will say things like I'm
going to help fight the culture War I'll
make a podcast and I'm like that's
really cool yeah do it if you want to do
it but we need more than that we need we
need bong companies you know what I mean
like we need companies that make things
like sodas and then if you make a soda
you sponsor someone Public Square I I I
I'm trying to figure out who they
sponsor but I remember seeing like a
video I think it's a BMX guy I'm not
sure or may be skateboarder but they're
wearing a Public Square shirt and I'm
like that's it right there because kids
are going to come to those events to
watch the guy do the backflip and he's
going to be wearing Public Square and
they're going to recognize that and I'm
hoping within a few years Public Square
is bigger than Amazon pipe dream but
when you get to that point where you
know every every business you're
shopping at here's the best part we need
to get to the point where businesses may
not actually have our values and share
the values of the nuclear family and you
know the the the Constitution but they
come out and say I'm all for it please
buy my product because that's what the
woke has and it's had for a long time
and they're losing they had this issue
where most businesses don't actually
care about wokeness but will fly the
flag because that's what they're
supposed to do you fly the American flag
that's what you're supposed to do and if
you don't know or care about the
Constitution fine but you fly the
American flag that's the indoctrination
we want so when conservatives are like
schools shouldn't be indoctrinating kids
no they should be they should be
indoctrinating them on American
constitutional values you should you
should raise your children to not to
hate you and your society and we have at
least a decade probably closer to two
decades of graduating classes who went
through an entire their entire life in
school where they were told that the
United States and liberalism is bad and
evil and produces only negative effects
you and the idea that that is a is going
to do anything other than destroy your
Society is ridiculous I used to hate the
public school indoctrination swear an
oath to a flag of allegiance that I
don't even understand but I'm pledging
my soul to this this corporate
Corporation Called the United States I
was like oh I hate it but now I'm I I'm
more like you're gonna get indoctrinated
by something so it may as well be the
American flag and then maybe that'll
point you at the Constitution and you'll
learn about it that's that's that's a
really really really good point there is
going to be some frame to the way that
you see Society right there's going to
be certain there's going to be a certain
way that you look at Society like you're
talking about they going to be
indoctrinated some way and that's really
all it is is just how you perceive
society and how you are how the the the
narrative that you believe your Society
you know that describes your Society so
if you're going to have some kind of
narrative that you're going to believe
then you might as well believe one that
is pro you and your family and the
people in your country the people that
are local to you you know I hope
everybody watches on Saturday I want you
know it's Pay-per-view on Saturday uh I
I think you can I'm pretty sure you can
go to like any sports bar they'll be
playing stck fight Strickland fight
Saturday January 20th Saturday
pay-per-view so uh we are definitely
going to be watching this mhm and uh I
hope everyone does because uh you want
to help build the parallel economy you
want to win a culture War you want UFC
and particularly the the the the uh the
fight with Strickland to be a smashing
success make tons of money and it's
going to no matter what but let's all uh
sit down enjoy the show tweet about it
make it Trend make it go viral and I I
hope Strickland wins I wonder if Dana
White visualizes his deal with Bud Light
as like a Jiu-Jitsu as like a UFC match
he's like I received their incoming
Force I grabbed it and now it's a ground
game I've got them on the ground with
their 100 million in my pocket let's see
if they can get out of this one and he
lets dudes like Sean just light fire
this is my point about declaring Victory
we now mock budlight relentlessly we
need budlight we should be saying things
like wow thank you budlight for
sponsoring that message they are
infections aren't they right
figuratively I'm not saying literally
say exactly what he said but make the
point that bud like funded this and
we're glad they did I will criticize a
little bit of what Shawn did there cuz I
I I don't like this is something and
maybe it's just me maybe there's room
for it to to really be like this this is
the Enemy of the State this guy right
here is all of your enemy he didn't say
the state no but he's like intimating
like this person is the enemy of your
reality it's that guy and like singling
out a human and telling everyone in the
room that that he's your villain
especially for a person in power is very
get that guy lynched so you got be
careful I have agree and I agree in the
sense that targeting a single individual
but I disagree in that we do need to use
mockery of bad and evil people that is a
powerful tool that's why memes are so
effective it's why political cartoons
are so effective so agreed pointing to a
single guy saying that's the enemy you
know like come on that guy's like a
doofy you know so I get it but
calling out the machine and saying these
are the behaviors that lead to death
destruction pain harm suffering Etc an
important thing to do and doing it in a
way that mocks and belittles cuz you
want to humiliate that reporter for sure
I mean that I think that's what Sean's
intent was he just did it in a really
like aggressive angry figh away more
than one he'll think twice before I ever
ask that question again though I'll tell
you that much yeah I think that that's a
a really good point and I think that
that's that's what he's intending to do
because really like that stuff doesn't
have anything to do with UFC nothing
it's all about it's all social questions
it's all questions about you know
culture War stuff um um right so and
that's and that's that's that's one of
the reasons why this is so great yeah he
says Trudeau freezes people's bank
accounts and that's what you're going to
ask me yeah and and you know what I love
how about another another good line is
exactly that to say things like do you
want to ask questions about fighting or
do you want to ask questions about
politics to get clicks on the internet
because that's what they're doing that's
why they do it they don't they don't
know anything about this guy I'm willing
to bet these Fighters he he's not going
to hear the name strictly ever again
he's not going to watch the fight he's
not going to care about the fight he's
going to leave and be like oh I don't
know I was assigned to go to something I
have no idea what it was I didn't see
the entire press conference where dudes
asking him about his ground game where
they ask him about his left hook like do
they talk are they actually talking
about his fight too imagine thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net